ils sont dix jeunes à tenir des ateliers
de prévention routière al aire
d'autoroute de limours janvry sur l'a10
dimanche 4 juillet le but est vraiment
sensibiliser les gens à la vigilance
notamment d'un point de vue avec tout ce
qui est somnolence sur l'autoroute
consommation de substances
donc voilà on conseille pour la
somnolence aux gens de s'arrêter toutes
les deux heures de faire une pause au
moins après ou plus s'ils sont vraiment
fatiguées
donc le but c'est vraiment d'être
ludique et pédagogique
cette mission d'intérêt général est
organisée dans le cadre de leur s et
annule le service national universel
pour sa ces jeunes âgés de 15 à 17 ans
ont choisi le thème de la prévention
routière et tout a été organisé par
leurs soins donc ce sont les jeunes
cadets qui ont monté leur action avec
l'aide d'un certain nombre de
partenaires qui devront apporter d un
certain nombre d'informations et qui ont
décidé du message qu'il voulait passer
puis de la forme dans laquelle il
voulait la faire passer nous avons
besoin de sensibiliser nos clients la
sécurité routière et donc ça tombait
vraiment très bien que ces jeunes lui
assènent ils veulent s'associer à cette
opération
les dix volontaires ont choisi de
s'engager auprès des cadets de la
gendarmerie
ce qui réjouit le lieutenant colonel
nicolas le guyader le fait de s'engager
comme ça ça génère une certaine
solidarité une cohésion au sein de
l'équipe et se s est venu c'est vraiment
ça c'est vraiment c'est donner du temps
personnel pour les autres et en fait
c'est très enrichissant dans le monde de
maintenant en france c'est près de 18000
jeunes qui réalisent leur service
national universel chaque année